[Music]
thank you thank you thank you for
introduction so yeah I have this like
kind of d double title M engineer and
Cloud solution
architect um I work between different
teams like data science and the wops
teams working to build like a nice
fruitful collaboration
uh in real life it looks like this
pretty much so if you ever try to
explain to data scientist why security
it's uh important or to the devops
engineers why data scientists need uh
production data in development
environment you know I'm basically in
the middle there like that lady trying
to uh connect the dots together so
um for this talk I took several
assumptions uh and I know like people
like like tooling and different uh
technology and stuff and everyone has a
preference but just to make it simple I
took three assumption one is that python
is basically the language for AI I know
like there's Julia K right people will
complain but let's uh think about this
uh in this way that uh python is
basically the interface or the language
for AI everyone use Python for that the
second thing is pytorch is the Deep
learning
framework um and the last one is that
Nvidia it's basic the main uh GPU
Monopoly of course there are other tools
available but if you open your like
Cloud uh uh list of computes that
available most probably there will be
Nvidia mostly there so basing uh on this
tack uh let's look what we can do
basically in model training and uh in
the inference to optimize our
models uh before that I think I have uh
should be one more slide there
H that's strange
well okay maybe it's later but anyway so
we have two stages right model training
and model inference I generated those
images with do tree and as you can see
model training looks very very nice and
model inference is just like bunch of
blocks uh connected with something and
no one really figured out what it is
there's a very nice name for the one of
the packages there it's like psych I
think something to take maybe for for a
next package if someone is looking for a
name but essentially during model
training we just experiment right we
have Jupiter we have a wi code we just
experiment we build the model the output
of it is at some file and then we in in
production we have a lot of different
Technologies built on top of that and we
would like to use it so here I have like
Onyx ony runtime very specific one also
for NVIDIA Triton so we will go into
those two stages oh no that was a slide
nice so uh a bit of the antihype uh
slide right like if you uh have
currently uh excel in production that
maybe you don't need
ml or latest llm uh in production by the
next of uh by the end of next week think
about it before you start doing anything
and also I think the one of the good
highlights of this year that we finally
have python support in Excel so people
all interested in L LS days but I guess
it's like deserves it right so think
about that but now let's jump to the
directly to the model uh training and
optimizing it so the first trick it's uh
uh mix Precision training very very
simple thing right like you have a float
32 so it eats up a lot of memory you use
half precision and then you save half
and then you speed up like by a factor
of three uh well that's uh good I think
uh you can just use it there are some um
of course practicalities right you see
the diagram over there let me see this
one particularly so if you just blindly
apply this and you start converting
parameters of your neural network to
like a lower Precision you will get a
lot of numerical inst stabilities if you
use pytorch or pytorch based framework
they kind of like uh uh automate for you
like I remember when it became available
like five years ago or something like
that it was like very difficult to use
now it's pretty much like a turnkey inst
solution you just enable it and you use
it um so uh yeah let me see something
else on the slide not uh really so
that's basically the main point of the
uh mix precision and you can use it
within the pytho ch system very well
Saves by factor of three for your
workload it can be different um I
noticed that sometimes it can be factor
of five depending on the network
depending on your training
Loop another thing is bdch size and
Optimizer so generally speaking uh you
want to maximize the utilization of your
computer right so you can uh pick a
batch size and usually the bigger budge
size the better while I'll say usually
sometimes it's not the case uh so you
want to maximize the budge size and then
when you do that uh you also would like
to tune your learning rate accordingly
to your budge size so they go hand in
hand and another thing that is mentioned
here is that uh choice of the optimizer
is very important so there are also
right now optimizers that support lower
precision and they uh all these um
parameters that you store for Optimizer
they can also uh improve a lot if you
use like quantise optimizers for example
like also by a factor of four or even
more and uh you don't have to do it also
manually so there are some techniques
that you can use also support in in most
of the deep learning Frameworks you can
find some routines that allow you to
pick uh preferable bdch size and
learning rate so you will start not just
guessing but with something really uh
aligned another thing um gradient
accumulation so this is not really
saving anything it's more like
overcoming limitation of your particular
uh compute so let's say you have one GPU
but but you really want to have that big
budge size uh like you cannot leave with
budge size of eight you need like really
64 or something like that so what you do
you basically uh chunk uh your uh bches
so you have like bunch of mini batches
and then you accumulate the gradients
over here and you do update only when
you reach your effective bdch size this
is just uh it's helpful sometimes and
you can go like I don't know to very
very very big budge sizes there if you
really would like to do it and it helps
uh better convergence of your algorithms
um but again it's not speeding up
anything it's just overcoming the
limitation another technique called
gradient
checkpointing this one is a lifesaver so
if you think about it we don't have to
store everything in the memory every
single uh at every single moment in time
right so we can only save some like
strategic points and particularly for
gradient like uh you can uh look for
example uh for Activation Maps right
uh during the forward pass you don't
need to store everything so you can just
store whatever you need the gradient
checkpointing deserves a separate talk
actually I just want to briefly mention
that but this one saves the memory and
speeds up your workload you can use both
also like with the one like with the
turnkey solution in pytorch or P torch
lightning so what else do we have uh
data preloading so there are a lot of
talks about data these days uh but I
still see people using one single thread
and they like a very powerful GPU that
just sits and waits like this track
there and you have like one worker
loading the data so very simple thing to
do here is that you
can uh first of all uh bump up the
number of uh workers like threats that
loading your data and you can also pin
the data to the memory so that's also
very simple to do in pytorch um and what
this will allow you to do is that you
can in parallel prepare your batches on
the CPU
while your GPU is doing the inference
and then you don't have this bottleneck
so that's very important to have these
two pieces in mind right that you have
powerful CPU that's busy and the GPU as
well is busy so you can maximize
utilization also very very simple thing
to enable uh but uh still a lot of
people missing that
part um now uh compilers I'm just going
to browse through it very qu very quick
but essentially I think for most data
scientist we operate on this level right
so maybe like this here so we have our
favorite framework not sure why I put
others I was focusing on P but anyway um
and then you have high level uh
representation which is your
computational graph and then it goes uh
forward until the machine code that is
basically optimized to run on the
particular GPU but there's like Steps in
the middle right so like usually this
topic is very uh important on inference
part on optimization but there's also
interesting thing that you can do during
training as well so like uh uh compilers
itself right so uh you have different
types of them um I particularly want to
emphasize the this block here the tuned
uh compile tuned layer so it goes via
different
uh via different intermediate
representation so computational graph
tuned intermediate representation low
level like something where Nvidia
compiler or l llvm is present and uh one
reason why you shouldn't trust
benchmarks there's this machine learning
performance uh Benchmark website where
all the companies put like a lot of
benchmarks uh well I'm pretty sure
Nvidia Engineers can optimize reset 50
on their Hardware just like really
manually programming and tuning it
performance so but for your workload if
you just take oneon-one some Network it
will not always perform the same way so
uh just beware of that but essentially
compilers are very important and uh the
nice thing in byor system right now is
that I think uh this year or like last
year end of last year they introduced
basically torch compile functionality
which um wraps your model and optimize
it also during the training and it's
basically Out of the Box gives you like
51% they claim again for your workload
can be different but whatever like if
you get it with one line of code why not
um of course compilation takes time
especially uh at the beginning of the
training like the first uh EPO will be
way longer than your regular one but
then the further one will be way
faster very very nice uh achievement I
think from the pyto team and here you
see also the representation that what
they do exactly when uh this process is
coming so they like they're acquiring
the graph very similar to the previous
picture that I showed then they do some
uh lowering of of the graph like merging
the layers and stuff like this and then
they support all kinds of different um
backends but on that a bit later so 51%
so I think if we'll start adding all the
techniques you will already speed up
very uh fast your
workload okay um now the obvious part
right I maybe I should have started with
this one so you most probably seen the
papers when uh researchers from some
Biga company use uh 10,000 gpus for two
months and they train the model and
school model we all can reproduce it of
course um so that's what about this so
multi-gpu training so as soon as you are
squeezed everything from your single GPU
for your model and you think like okay
it takes long I have way more data
coming you go to this multipu setting
there are a lot of uh techniques that
you can use there data parallelism is
the most uh common one essentially what
you do you just copy your model
uh to set of gpus and then you run uh
parts of your data basically on each GPU
and you synchronize sometime and the
level of synchronization diver between
different techniques so in pytorch
ecosystem it's uh distributed data
parallel is very common one really
suggest to take a look data parallel is
less but I mean it's all differences are
in the communication overhead and how
you update the parameters uh of your
networks um let me see yeah there's also
Al uh briefly mentioned tensor parallel
and model parallel and it all boils down
to how you slice your model so tensor
parallel just you run first half of the
model for example just slice it like
like this you run one half on one GPU
and another half of another one and T
are parallel when you cut it model like
this so you basically have your graph
and then you just split like matrix
multiplication it's very paralyzable you
can run it across several gpus but
that's very specific and um yeah in some
cases you might use it but mostly people
use data
parallelism one more technique that I
want to highlight here which just like
saves a lot of memory if you're really
into the business of like taking maximum
from your gpus that you have it's called
Uh Z raw um and uh the way how you can
think about this is like if you organize
a
party in the data parallel in a previous
scenario the party will look like this
so you have like set of friends and
every friend brings
everything that's needed for a party so
everyone comes like one friend brings
everything beer pizza napkins everything
and then they sit together all the
friends they eat mostly and they just
sometimes occasionally talk with each
other so it's a data parallel if you
substitute friends as a gpus this method
is actually like a normal party instead
of uh uh one person like bringing
everything each friend brings something
and they uh share it uh with each other
and they just basically uh enjoy joining
the party and they talk a lot that's
what happening here essentially so this
is basically standard one and this is
the zero so parameters of the network
shared between set of the gpus and they
talk with each other a lot during
forward and backward pass uh and it's
very amazing technique Microsoft
basically uh states that okay if you
want to train a trillion parameter model
with this technique you will just need
uh what's that thousand of gpus and 60
GB of video memory for each GPU I mean I
think it's very very reasonable very
nice and uh yeah uh feel free to give it
a try so
uh that's about um optimizing model
training now a bit of the code so I
cannot just uh remove my devops hat and
then I need to say that so organize your
code into the python package I guess
it's obvious but uh maybe not for some
people that just if you write something
think python packages they are sharable
you will make your devops people happy
and yeah then another thing use Jupiter
notebook as a front end for your uh
application what it means is that you
start writing in Jupiter and then you
there's this always moment in time when
your uh notebook becomes uh a no novel
right like very very long and you need
to scroll up and down and stuff like
that I know that there's different
techniques to make Jupiter notebook
production ready uh freeze the state use
paper meal what kind of I mean you can
use it if you want but please don't and
uh just if you write something you
sketch use notebook as notebook it's
called for that uh notebook for the
reason and another thing is the
containers so if you're data scientist
look at containers I think all other
thing your uh infrastructure team and
the team can figure out for you but if
you can package it in container it's
very very
nice all the techniques that I mentioned
before I highly suggest you go hands on
and just try to implement them and the
nice part is that this uh there's this
framework by TCH lightning which I think
uh yeah it has it has support for
different accelerators it has different
uh devices like you can put multiple
gpus there you can play with precision
and all the techniques that I mentioned
gradient checkpointing gradient
accumulation everything is available
there so you don't really need to
implement things but you can tra some
model and see how much speed up you can
get on your uh computer
now we go to the boring part which is uh
inference um and optimization for the
inference
so quite standard way of thinking about
that is that you have some model right
like this pth file in pytorch and then
in order to run it on some particular
Hardware you need to optimize it on top
of that right so in this case there's
set of
Technologies uh those those two are uh
related to interpretability and
optimization of the model and then Onyx
runtime it's just like run time to run
it very high performance one and then in
the end it all goes to some server so
you have some serving solution for your
uh ml models and uh let's look into all
of these things together and also
discuss the problems uh that can occur
so onx it's uh very uh like open neural
network exchange sounds like some kind
of like uh broker or something like that
but anyway um this is very helpful if
you have multiple teams working in
different Technologies one team speaks
pytorch another team speaks mlab or I
don't know torf flow um and uh you are
devops engineer and you think like okay
I don't want to learn uh particular uh
propriatary graphs of these uh neural
network Technologies I just want to run
it in some standard format that's how
Onyx came into the picture it basically
allows you to convert it to something
that you can share easily with the
within the company and and the nice part
is that while initially Onyx was focused
on um neural network support only it
also supports psychic learn and all and
other techniques like a traditional
machine learning which is also very
great we still do traditional machine
learning right um so that's about ony
Onyx runtime it's basically an next
Evolution step right so you have that
model you want to run it and you want to
apply a lot of optimization to that um
ony in this case
supports this execution provider so
basically each and every Hardware
manufacturer or their team of Engineers
they Implement those providers over here
and then you can just plug it in easily
so it's more like on an open source
ecosystem so in case if you want to run
machine learning model on uh fpga for
example um or on some other device like
uh from any other manufacturer you can
implement the provider and use it so
it's it's very nice and it's also uh
very very fast run time so I would
suggest it as a first choice like
especially if you are in that ecosystems
so if you're using Onyx already Onyx
runtime integrates very well with
that uh there will be another talk about
quantization uh later on today uh I will
just go on top of that so uh What uh uh
what exactly it is and uh why it's also
helpful so we discussed mixed Precision
training and um uh mix Precision
training helps during speed up things
during the training and quantization is
the concept that I introduced for
inference so imagine you have very low
profile Edge device and you really would
like to make your model very very small
and very very performant so you use
quantization and this is the picture
basically how um the view of the world
is changing uh if you change the amount
of uh bits per pixel and the accuracy as
well so quite often you will lose
performance when you do quantization
because it's usually very harsh you can
go like up to in8 or even lower these
days and uh you need to really see and
monitor the quality of your model if
it's still performing to your uh
evaluation
metrics one interesting technique here
is this quantization aware training uh
which allows you to simulate what's
going to happen with your model when you
apply those harsh uh uh quantization
like how it will perform on the training
uh time and basically uh that's uh about
it and a lot of these Frameworks like
going forward for example TZ RT again
this is NVIDIA specific right you have
Nvidia
GPU and you want to optimize performance
on that GPU what you do you run tzor RT
tzor RT is outputting uh some engine uh
uh out of it and it supports
quantization of our training post-
trining quantization and all these
things that I mentioned before out of
the box and uh basically the only
downside is that if you optimize on one
GPU and then Somewhere in Time you
decide just to switch gpus you will need
to do it again because you may have
actually uh worse performance so that's
uh not nice but then it also runs all
this optimization as well as Onyx
runtime so you have here like layer
tensor Fusion weights calibration kernel
autot tuning all these things are done
for you and it speeds up significantly
the inference time for your gpus for
your models
sorry um let me see yeah the last bit
this is mostly relevant I think for
companies um but let's say you have uh
multiple models that you would like to
host um in a simple scenario you may
think like okay I can have I have my
model I can just uh put fast API on top
of that and be happy with this yeah I
think for for experiments it works well
but uh if you go in a scale you need
something more and usually even not like
focusing on Tron particularly but you
need these components right so you
usually have different types of work you
have a botch workloads that's running
maybe daily you have real-time workloads
like the API someone is calling some API
and you have also streaming sometimes
and you would like to accumulate that
all in your serving solution right you
need different interfaces uh grpc uh
HTTP that works there you want to
support multiple backends in this case
like uh uh Tron supports like um all of
the things that you use usually like a
standard stack and uh uh quite often you
have a dedicated model registry where
all your models are landing so you can
basically deploy them there are multiple
other things one important aspect here
is that you want to save costs unless
you're running uh GPU cluster on Prem I
think most of the companies they use
public Cloud so you want to make sure
that for the money that you pay for GPU
you get maximum out of it and they're
not idling and those those solutions
they are helping very well for that plus
they also integrate with a lot of system
I think world runs on kubernetes these
days mostly so you can also import all
the metrics and you would like to know
where things go wrong and all those kind
of
things um so the point being here it's
not necessary about Triton but if you
want to go uh like
um I don't know like more or less
professional about serving your models
you need a solution but there are
multiple of them and also in open source
I mean TZ tzer Tron is open source but
there is also other uh Technologies open
source that uh you can use um and
they're all serving what you need but
then um back to the to this picture uh I
personally don't like that we have to go
like okay we python is the best language
right but it was already mentioned that
python is kind of like a duct tape
language or like interface language
right so we all go down to C++ and then
we go uh even further so if I put head
of data scientist I don't care I just
want to write a python code and I want
it to be performant can I have it please
the answer so far was not really okay I
mean just uh stay with this right you
have this duality of the language python
uh C++ then afterwards you have all
these Technologies right okay I need to
now learn torrt Onyx I need to run the
runtime here it's already kind of a
boundary between uh serving and uh ml
engineering I would say um why we cannot
have it in Python right because python
is slow right so uh Global interpreter
log you cannot do a lot of things there
so that's why we use all other uh
languages underneath and then you always
have this problem that if you want to
debug something you need to go to
another language and back and forth so
this year moo was introduced who heard
about
moo okay who haven't heard about Mojo
check their website they also doing a
conference and uh I would not
recommended for production workloads but
as idea it's very powerful and
implementation is very nice it's like uh
the way how they optimize the models
they use uh some AI also there on that
level to optimize it on the target
Hardware so you can Trash the Cuda you
can Trash a lot of things and then just
write Python and then here I need to put
like a uh disclaimer that uh the P
python that's in Mojo it's not really a
python it's a kind of combination with
system programming as well so I would be
very curious like to to see how people
react on that because some people like
it some people think like okay this is
like another language but they promise
that modu essentially is a uh is an
interface uh it's a super set of pythons
so like kind of python Plus+ and uh try
to write some multi-layer perceptron in
modu and see how fast it's performing I
really love it I'm using it for some
like experimentation and also another
thing back to LMS because these days we
measure everything as a tokens per
second I I think uh next year on the
Apple conference they will see like new
iPhone it can do thousand tokens per
second uh on the latest llm and people
be like oo yes um so this is the
benchmarks for Mojo uh for llama 7 uh B
model I think it's M1 uh Max uh MacBook
uh so
basically not saying anything bad about
those guys but if you see the comparison
on the inference for C++ and Mojo and
the time that's very promising and
that's what I think uh overall Community
should go that we have that we solve
that problem that we don't need to think
about Hardware because if you see the
news these days every single um uh
Hardware manufacturing they keep
developing new Chips right because
everyone wants to win and have have a
full stack like own the hardware on the
software so like you can pay more money
and this is very nice that you can just
switch between different Hardwares so
it's a I really like the promise of this
uh particular uh framework so check it
out and and I think that's it there's
some uh links there that uh references
that you can also take a look I highly
encourage you to go Hands-On approach uh
we discussed a lot of tricks so I hope
it will help you in your workloads thank
you so
much uh thank you for the excellent
presentation I think we've time for
maybe one or two questions uh if someone
in the audience has one yep
oh uh thanks for your presentation I
have a question about um managing
modeling production about monitoring and
maintenance what kind of Frameworks out
are out there for yeah keeping track of
them and monitoring and keeping track of
drift performance and S like that not
only for deep learning but also for more
say classical machine learning
models
that's very interesting question and
tricky in the same time so there's this
diagram of the all possible tools that
you can use if we print it I think it
can cover this whole room but uh there
are multiple tools so for example if
you're in particular Cloud vendor quite
often the uh tooling for monitoring that
they provide can easily be adopted for
this machine learning workloads if you
need something specific depending which
kind of model you're using if it's a
what kind of tasket this time series
prediction image classification then
there are specialized tools uh also for
that um I Ed for example evidently uh
it's a very nice library to use uh for
monitoring and drift prediction but it
varies it's really we can have
discussion later on if you want but it
really depends on the use case that
you're working on where you host your
model what's is available already in the
serving engine that you use and what you
would like to monitor but like concept
drift model drift you can monitor in
standard tools they now I think uh
ecosystem is improving and improving and
every day there are new and new tools
are released so you will find something
there in the stack definitely but it
really depends on what model you are uh
looking into
yeah I think it was one over over here
long throw long throw
uh
no hey um okay so um I wonder sometimes
if there's also a reason just to train
the Deep learning thing on a CPU
partially because we're all GPU poor
these days but also because I wonder if
it can also be cheaper if you're willing
to be patient have you looked at any of
that um not training uh but inference
definitely and also um if you look at
the scope of the computer that we have
sometimes there are gpus that developed
for this purpose for for example AWS
they have uh one of the type of gpus I
don't remember exactly the name right
now but uh you can start inferring if
you want to save on the CPUs for
training it's still very very uh time
consuming depends on the network also
use but but let's say if you want to
optimize time you need to see what kind
of network you training right how much
time one EPO uh takes and you can go
with this and see okay if you if you
have time you can wait but if it's
something serious these days networks
are very uh big uh but it's an
interesting trial I think like from like
cost perspective optimization I would
say that if you have like a if you can
run a CPU for like couple of months and
it's something not very important you
can just keep it running and let's say
maybe you did some initial optimization
of the parameters on the GPU but then
you just need to train your model
regularly and you really don't care how
long it takes maybe you can wait a week
why not I mean I'm all for it just uh
save some money and the compute as well
because indeed we are GPU
poor all right I'd like to keep it on
track I thought there was one more
question but maybe we can do that uh in
the hallway track um thank you very much
for the presentation on behalf of the
committee uh a small thank you and free
coffee for the rest of the thank you
thank you thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you